ladies and gentlemen I can with
confidence tell you that we are bringing
it back what is it this shirt honor
shirt is back yes you can buy this shirt
once again and this is the final final
time we are ever bringing back this set
so if you missed out on our drop with
aari we are bringing back all of the
popular items that you enjoyed on screen
right now you can see some of the
pictures of the merchandise we are
bringing back some of your favorite
pieces from that collection and offering
them one last time to you guys again
some of the items are the after dark
hoodies the after dark sweatpants the
after dark split shirt and of course the
lavender shirt the Connor shirt I
already have three of them and the main
reason why we're bringing these back is
because I need 30 more of them so if you
want to get your hands on some of this
iconic merch it is only available for a
very short time so make sure that you
grab it now pre-orders run from January
26th to February 9th PST and if you buy
one of the Connor shirts and meet me in
the Conor shirt I will give you a
picture a handshake and maybe a kiss on
the cheek who knows how Saucy we can get
so I hope that I can expect many of you
at home rocking the Connor shirt very
soon get them while you can now the last
podcast I brought up that you sang Take
On Me Yeah and Sweden we did it oh my
God I told you not
to
no uh welcome back to another episode of
trash taste once again joined by the
boys Jerry and G and this time another
special guest fix is back back a year
later or more yeah isn't it how long's
it been has it been a year it does I
checked before it was 124 episode it
said a year on you a year and a
bit what is this one this
is0 something what epod than
year well it's well it's also I think a
momentous occasion because you are the
first dad ever on trash am I really I
think so no [__] way I don't think
we've ever had a dad before I'm sure one
of our I can't be the only dad I can't
can you think of anyone who we've had is
apparent like at the time they came on
to the show like Raina nor
yeah edit that out I'll claim the title
only only that on the show you are the
second dad on the show you are the only
person that has become a dad in between
the first time coming
on that's achievement incredible one fun
thing that happened is that I guess
because after the episode when you
obviously announced that um you're
having a a kid we'd actually brought it
up on TR on that trash and you were like
you were like how did they know we
didn't know yeah we just really get we
just brought it up for some reason it
was really [__] weird I remember
sitting here it was too early to
announce it and you're you guys just
bring up my hypothetical child and I'm
just
like how do they know what the [__] you
know how women have like the pregnancy
glow I'm like do I have the dad glow is
going on you already getting giving off
Dad energy
yeah the dad energy is knowing you don't
have to be the one to give birth that's
just you're like you're like
stoked like feel way happier than normal
yeah you sat down you just groaned a
certain way you're like oh he's getting
ready oh he's he's a d that was really
trippy I genuinely was like what the
[__] how did they know it really freaked
me out to
be wellit how long ago when we filmed
that episode like how long was it that
you knew that uh I don't remember
exactly but it was quite a reason like
to tell other okay I'll just stop making
things now then I'll just St saying
things stop predicting you freak me out
why would you do that
so hemorrhoids
right oh my
gosh that'd be so funny if anyone's got
hemor oh [__] so hilarious these chairs
hurt so I guess obvious first question
we want to ask you is well obvious first
thing is congratulations congrat
congrats but uh first question is what's
it like being a dad now that you're a
dad now no
sleep I don't even remember what it felt
like to be properly rested yeah 4 hours
every day no no no no no no six maybe oh
okay yeah do that for five months yeah
okay yeah I knew
that's so B yeah once maybe it's not
just your early it's not just your early
youtubeer was you was younger he was
younger back then not just every you now
I can't do it
anymore godamn oh God no it's great yeah
it's really fun I how was it I guess
having a child in a foreign country
especially like Japan I think a lot of
people be to know like was it was it is
it easy was it was there a lot of funny
little things you didn't expect or
probably more question from Mara to be
honest yeah true you you like chilling
you like yeah you're just chilling man
yeah I mean yeah it's it's different for
sure yeah yeah I'm amazed she was able
to do that like in a foreign
country the [__] were we thinking but
yeah yeah I mean especially cuz your kid
probably has the worst name for Japanese
people to pronounce sound that bad it
how do they say it how do they say how
would the Japanese people
sayun okay cuz I was thinking it was
just going to
beong maybe six but they have the it's
really popular here the baby brand baby
be oh yeah so you just reference there
you go it happened just
now yeah they know it so they're like oh
like oh same same so that works uh so
you got to figure it out that's it it's
easy just just name your kid after a
brand I just remember I asked you I was
like is bero like is that a bad name you
were like no it's
great and now I come here and you say
word double check like is it bad in
Japanese doesn't mean anything else you
asked you asked me is it you asked me is
it a does it mean anything bad in
Japanese yeah and I said no no you said
that's a beautiful name yeah and I think
it's a beautiful name it doesn't change
the fact that I think it's hard for
Japanese people to pronounce talking mad
[__] behind yeah he he was saying the
wildest [__] who the
[__] should we get our coffees yeah it
means bear in oh it's so funny actually
milk for him and soy honey for me yeah
sorry I'm the oak guy but maybe is
coming is coming order oh yeah you want
mine you have M you the guest I didn't
get
Guatemala you did get Guatemala
Guatemala uh sorry what you saying oh no
I had to reorder theirs so that's for
everyone else that's for Kai you and
Alex sorry I forgot what I was going to
say means bear it means bear oh okay
yeah yeah CU we always go to the
vacination and whatever check up and
it's always just me mar and a bunch of
moms yeah Japanese dads don't exist I
one uh well they don't go in the uh you
were saying that it's not common for
Japanese dads to be in the uh the room
when yes the mm's giving birth yeah
which is it's a very Japanese mentality
if you're like ah I'll see him when he's
when he's clean and Stu and yeah it's
also the worst cuz they were also you
know it's against the uhul No No No the
pink killer thing like no you should
have a natural birth as
Welles only reason the Japanese women
are like no yeah yeah yeah you have to
like you have to either go to a specific
hospital or you have to like really push
for common yeah like were you in the
room uh yeah they brought me in for the
finale yeah for the finale so so you
were just like chilling playing I wasn't
there for the entire season but I was
there for the final
episode they gave me a rund down you
know and you like posted on Twitter guys
it was a hard for 12 hours but it was
worth it they they gave you
the they gave you the cliff notes what
were you doing then during the they kept
me at home yeah you you at home you just
chilling like I wasn't even allowed to
be outside yeah W they were like M say
was the one that had to text me too it
wasn't even like the nurses talking to
me or something oh my God so she texting
giving you up yeah yeah yeah and she's
like okay come now and then I yeah I
didn't hear anything for a while and I
was like I wonder if I have time to pee
and then of course as soon as I go to
the bathroom she's like come now and I'm
like uh but yeah they brought me in for
the highlight and everything went great
so yeah happy yeah Japan's service is
really good with child bear so that's a
good part of all that I me they they got
to make it good it's a rare event they
got to get it's becoming once a year
thing they got to make it as appealing
as it Poss yeah I think they have the
lowest child death in in among the world
I think yeah careers I think fertility
is different from birthrate I is it I
can't remember if it is there's a whole
bunch of statistics about it okay point
being no one wants to have babies yeah
well cuz you can't cuz you when is it
your turn yeah when is it I'm doing what
you guys did to me now your
reference how do he know how does he
know okay giv off the glow why are we
ask them watch them bit when when is it
yeah Joey yeah Joey when's what do you
mean you're the married you're you're
the closest G as closest yeah I mean I
mean it's something I mean I talked
about it pressure I was just joking oh
no I get enough pressure for my family
any this is how she got to find out your
M anything compared to going to a family
family reunion getting the 20 different
aunts asking me that's like that's like
hard mode this is just like chill but uh
yeah I mean I guess it will come when it
will this is not any hint stop looking
at my eyes and
like studying my body language to Gemini
he's lying right now actually this
is but uh I think I want a kid sometime
in the next few years that's what I
think I don't I don't kind of know maybe
it'll happen earlier maybe it'll happen
later who knows when you're ready you're
ready yeah exactly were you ready do you
think yeah well yes or no I guess yeah
you get you get nine months to prepare
yeah you're not
prepared
we were yeah we were trying to like uh
find all the pay to pay to win our way
through like getting all the every
Amazon baby machine there is we're going
to solve baby raising I thought you
meant the pay to win for conception I
was just like I guess you do that that
do that too you can do that I guess yeah
uh yeah it's it's hard
so what's the most hardest thing you've
had to learn as a dad sleep sleep for
sure sleep it really kills you after a
while yeah I guess you just have to
sleep when the baby sleeps that's the
common thing that people say yeah what a
great idea Connor just I wouldn't know
the baby doesn't sleep what do you mean
he's got to sleep he's got to sleep at
some point he's when he's got up every
hour go crazy [__] now we're going to
sleep training soon and I can't wait
it's going to be great you just sent
them off to boarding
school this guy suggestions too oh my
God no it's great you should get the
Asian mentality which it just pass it
off to or like their grand
yeah be like that would have been very
helpful like Mom Dad you take care of
the baby for a weekend let us well they
a lot of uh a lot of like um interesting
uh articles have been raised about how
like a lot of people nowadays don't have
their grandparents raising kids and it's
like one of the reasons why a lot of
people don't want to have kids it's like
they don't have any other external
supports when you were when you were
growing up right you had aunts you had
your uh you know grandparents helping
you and whoever else and but now it's
kind of mostly on the parents the
grandparents I mean it's especially
tough like you know in your instance
because all of your family extended
family doesn't live in Japan yeah
grandparents would have been helpful
yeah for sure I think my I think my
older brother because I've got a nephew
I think he moved back to go near my like
parents house like just that makes and
they're pros at that point they're like
no concerns I feel like when you if I
had a kid I'd be very worried about
everything yeah where I think
grandparents are like nah [__] it we'll
figure it out do this you will fine fine
yeah it'll be fine yeah well am I
fine they raed a weird kid I think Mar
is they worrying oh really you're like n
was F it
whatever are there any like weird skills
you have to learn in preparation like
the N9 months much [__] to learn cuz I I
I want to know what I've got like what
I've got to like I guess look forward to
I'll help you
out what's the what's the what's the cuz
I think when I want to have a kid right
I want to like I want to like make him
like cool so I I would start from day
one I'm like all right start showing him
cool stuff right away subconsciously
making him think that like video games
are cool okay I think they will like
that anyway they will like that anyway
but like the right video games I'll give
like two piles of like Foods one will
have Subway Surface one will have Elden
ring and he crawls towards and if he
goes towards the subway stuff he gets no
food that's the so he just has to learn
he goes to boarding
school and then he and then he resents
me but at least he'll be
decision the right this is a joke by the
way
that's an interesting approach yeah
consider it you should you should really
take this like I no children you should
really consider that no no I'll do that
yeah what age do you think you going to
let your uh let your kids start gaming
as soon as possible soon as possible
absolutely gamer baby he's going to be
playing like the worst games you're
going to be disappointed no no no no any
game I'll
play it's like he's five months so they
can't really do much yeah yeah my my
family's like what can you do now I'm
like yeah still a baby like what what
age do they start doing stuff like d d
like poke it with a stick like come on
come on I mean you can play with him for
sure but like yeah it's I me Radley
noises it's not like I they don't St
walking for like another 5 months at
least right we speed that up I didn't
realize how long he I we speed that up a
little bit speedrun
strp Speed Run raise a
CH the walk yeah first words what like
what was it like first words how long
does that take normally can can I should
know that uh no uh I think it's like a
year maybe a year okay I think you learn
a walk before you learn your first words
right or is it the other way around I I
should know that yeah I don't know I
don't know how long does it take yeah
speaking their first words in 11 to 13
months 11 to 13 month Fu they slow aren
they he's already accidentally they they
say mama all the time he doesn't know
what it means this is a sound they make
and I'm like Mom's rigged
it have no chance to be Papa first right
yeah you're done you're done yeah you
can be the cool dad no yeah for sure
you're going to be the cool dad right
well the fun dad I guess yeah okay well
I I saw you've written off cool dad
you're like we'll see I saw you trying
to learn as many cool things as possible
and like this and a short a time period
to impress your son what do you think is
like what what's the funnest thing that
you've learned that you think will be
the most impressive [__] no yeah I
don't know bab are amazed by anything
like you can show him anything and he's
like wow so I don't know must be a big
confidence booster yeah yeah it's great
just seeing the B yeah yeah he laughs at
anything it's hilarious I am pretty
funny I know speak speaking of that I do
love the way BJ laughs it's very cute he
just sounds like an old man he sounds
like an old man he's
like she doesn't know how to laugh it's
really cute yeah I saw you uh when you
you learning your skills you did this uh
the art video where
you off your art journey and I I I am
yeah I saw I don't know you put it in
see I don't think you're on Twitter but
it's kind of sent Twitter into a really
interesting uh conversation a lot people
like what the [__] he actually got good
okay nice a lot of people were very like
imp it was not like any negative or
anything but it was very people were a
lot talking about it a lot like I
definitely don't want to piss off the
art community no it's generally that
there were some people who are like I'm
a lot of people are like that's [__]
up that I took me 5 years years to get
to where he got uh like stuff like that
but you know it was a really it was a
really interesting video you cuz they
hate you yeah and I guess you didn't
even realize people you'd caus a bit of
a conversation on Twitter yeah a lot of
people were talking about it what made
you wanted to get into there I don't
know just a random whim so where's so
what's your dard account I don't have
it I you know I watched I watched that
video and I was watching I was like man
I I I'm impressed that you don't get
frustrated with this and want to stop no
I got really frustrated how how do you
keep going I don't it's for a son
no know real real reasons only Jo I just
want to draw cute anime girls come on
face all right well that's that's a good
enough reason I do get that question a
lot and I I generally I don't know you
don't know you have no idea what I'm
just we a different man all right all
right about the grand s okay all right I
wake up at 5:00 a.m. cuz the kid wakes
you up
yes as soon as I saw you doing that
video and saw you like I'm going to
choose to draw girls I was like yeah my
man my man
knows stra you didn't want to go for
muscular man or maybe that's the next
step yeah muscles are hard I think I
guess that's exactly right yeah that's
fine I'm still doing it I find it
amusing that you found anime girls to
draw easier than like any other art
style do you think anime is just an
easier art style to begin yeah cuz it's
kind of stripped down of it's not
realistic looking right so there's like
there's like a weird formula to it as
well right that's like a little bit
harder to kind of deviate from even if
you wanted to cuz like if you deviate a
little bit from the anime art style it
just doesn't it look yeah yeah yeah you
try and give them lips and it's like
what the [__] is this it looks cursed as
hell you make their draw their nose like
what the [__] is this yeah like an anime
character with dsls just looks a little
bit little weird it doesn't work I think
it's cuz the ice are so big anything
else just kind yeah don't takes up a lot
of room yeah but it gives me hope
because I think I have like negative art
skills and seeing how you should try it
yeah fast yeah I do I do I see how fast
you improved in such a short period of
time or maybe you're just Talent like
naturally talented talented at it I
don't know I don't know you're are good
at a lot of things this annoying you're
so you're so n you're good you have one
floor please yeah
uh God damn it this is the cool dad by
the way what's your what's your biggest
biggest floor what's your biggest floor
uh all biggest
Flor well I I realized the other day I'm
not I'm not actually a good
person okay all right okay elaborate
elaborate well cuz if I'm doing
something nice for other people for
normal people I imagine it's just like
oh of course for me it's like it hurts
me what you well like okay if I'm
driving oh actually we had this
conversation yeah if I'm driving and I
have to let someone go I'm like God
[__] damn you for letting have making
me do this cuz he he was in the wrong
lane right yeah completely the wrong
lane and everyone was lining up in the
right lane which we needed to be in and
and I was like yeah just you know go in
so someone will let you in and then 2
minutes later there was the opposite
situation happened we were ining we were
in the right kept eging me on for the
record no no no and someone else was
kind to join our lane and I was like you
should should let let them in because we
just someone else just let us in and
he's like I don't want
to I was like I was like you're a piece
of [__] you did yeah because I you
because I made you feel bad about it I
do if no one was in the car with you you
would be like I think about all those
times where I'm driving and I have to
make this exit and I'm and some Saint
lets me in the lane he's like fine which
is me cuz I do it me to do it no I don't
want to if I ever see you drive I don't
want you to let me in I know you don't
want to do it I I'll wait for the next
call I think it actually makes me a
better person because it's harder for me
to do it so if anything I'm better than
a good person so why do you do it then
if you don't want to do it cuz I Society
Society societal pressure I would say
Society is working as intended then
because you feel you feel
shame [__] makes me godam it so you
okay so let me get this straight let me
get this straight you're sitting there
you know be beond just finally can't be
the only one just judging come no no no
no beond just gone to bed beond just
gone to bed you finally get an hour to
think you have me you you know you
finally get to relax and think you think
man yeah I didn't let that car I'm a bad
[__] no I don't I don't let it linger
I I don't care no you're definitely not
the only one but you're probably the
first to admit that Society has grounded
you well in that way I think it's it's I
think you know sometimes you do this
thing where okay I think you you're
genuinely nice a lot of the times but
there are sometimes where you're like I
should be nice here and you've decided
to be nicer yeah and that's a conscious
thought that you've made you didn't
think about it and you didn't just
compulsively do it you're like the
options which is way nicer CU you're
making you're making an effort but then
I feel like sometimes I'm like man am I
acting nice is that who I really am but
I but I I still chose to do the nice
thing or perceive nice thing this is too
deep for me I think that I'm good but it
[__] me out it [__] me up sit there
and I'm like am I a bad person that I
didn't immediately think to do I think
if you think you're a good
person but it's also like sometimes you
just sometimes just also in like the
mood to do something nice I gu sometimes
you're just in a happy mood and should
doing something nice always be mood yeah
that's a good point that's a good point
that's a good point do you guys drive
here uh often I don't he doesn't have a
license I've already driven like I I
have a license but I don't drive too
often me what you going to say well I
the reason I realize is because of the
blinking that people do they do use a
hazard lights as a thank you oh yeah
yeah and I asked Conor do you count the
blinks that they give you cuz in my head
I thought this was like a system that
everyone developed this dude made up an
entire kind of system I'm not crazy
explain explain explain so basically
what so basically what fix is saying is
if someone I don't like what this Fu
making me if Felix lets someone in and
then they go into the lane in front of
them and then they click the hazard
lights to Blink say thank you right
Felix is there sitting there being like
they only blinks once yes absolutely
only blinks once that's slap in the face
I was like what are you talking about I
blink once with the that's so people use
the hazard lights in the car to to say
thank you right and I say I press it
once cuz I don't want people to think
there a [__] hazard
yeah no one do this it once yes they do
on highways on highways they do you do
you do it once as like a thank you and
that's they should be they should be
that's that's any more than that you're
going to be like oh they're actually in
trouble listen here's how it works three
blings is like oh dude thank you so much
no that's four is way too much way to an
accident I do really nice thing
sometimes I expect the four just leave
it up I know what to why why turn it off
just say thank you the entire
one is like [__] off that
was no B is [__] off no one does a one
that only Connor does it I no that is
not true what is this the American
tipping system right now yes it is I
gave one blink how bad was my service I
guess I'm just that nice driving then
because I never get it one how many
times do you do it all the time well
like how long how many blinks well three
is like I said thank you so much two is
like all right thank you appreciate it
so it depends never heard this this is
why you don't let people through cuz
they only blink to you once so you think
they're ungrateful exactly they're like
no one's ever grateful enough we're
saying that the amount of you know when
you do the hazard light say thank you it
doesn't matter how many blinks you leave
it on for it matters does that mean how
many thank you you're giving yes it is
that's that's why I leave it at least
three
yes let's
go at least three crazy no I'm Googling
this after because three and more is
there's a fin line between oh my God I
appreciate this so much and help me I I
was driving so glad you're here so here
if someone does two to me I be pissed
yes that's right that's
right no and what would one be one is
just disrespectful I would get that's it
that's
it what are you talking about one is the
same as like getting flipped off okay
Reddit is saying twice I've never heard
in between in between everything Reddit
doesn't know [__] this is like a
language that some people have made for
themselves and no one else is following
you guys have made up this language I'm
not C learn this because this is this
isn't in any like Drive the thank you
yeah the thank you I think it's like a
it's like a virus it spreads like you
just see a guy do it you're like oh that
makes sense I'll do that next time
someone that's how I learned they do
that in the UK and I was like Dad why
are you do putting the hazard lights on
and he was like oh I'm just saying thank
you so that's the most annoying [__] in
UK cuz it's always dark and then they
hazard light you're like [__] I
didn't need that yeah that's why we
already
you know to show real kindness I just
get out of my car and thank them I leave
I use the the the front lights to get
someone's attention that's what I mean
not the hazard lights you use the hazard
lights in UK I Ed I use the front lights
to get someone's attention yeah like
they say thank you and UK with it yeah
you can do that too yeah a especially on
like country no like cuz like what if
someone let you in then you say you
Flink cuz you can't they can't see your
hazard light so you you flick the front
ones to say yeah but they blind you I
don't I like it that's a d That's a dumb
thing oh my you drive a Tesla it drives
the car okay I you don't drive the car
be it's reasons like this that I like
every time I go to a new country I'm
[__] [__] my pants about what the
rules are cuz every rule is different
okay so okay say you're like in ja super
respectful driving rules you have to bow
after you have to stop the car and
bow so
this so this is something I learned when
I was like moved to Thailand so you're
at a junction right yeah and and there's
a car coming and he blinks twice using
front lights what does that mean he's
letting you go he's saying go ahead so
in tiand if you see that that means do
not [__] go cuz I am not going to
slow down so that's psychotic behavior
my brakes are broken that should there
should not be a signal for that you
shouldn't be allowed to communicate that
no that Mak would be perfect for that no
cuz this [__] would be going Dr
the highway [__] flicking the entire
time you a me on when I drive I'm super
nice driver no okay the only time I eged
him on is there was a long line and it
you're like just take advantage take
advantage of the Japanese kindness
that's what he told me the line the line
was literally it was like an hour long
and I was like we could do listen we're
on a tight schedule here drive to the
front and merge and cut in be a dick
right did devil on my shoulder he did it
and we got and we got through right away
it's a huge dick move don't do this but
we were in such a rush so yeah yeah yeah
but no F be like that's a great idea and
I shouldn't have Tau
him he he wanted someone to just
acknowledge Him and say it to him but
now I'm the good person you
know Conor you sure are you sure Conor
yes I'm sure Felix well jeez I guess
Conor skip like a 100 cars cut right in
before the turn off aw yeah that's a
that's an awesome thing to do don't do
that unless he also doesn't tip in Japan
what a damn
joke oh my God so have you uh you think
you've acclimated Japan now then it's
like year now I think I need more time
actually you need more time I mean it
took a long time even UK where I felt
like oh yeah everything's set up I'm
good we didn't go to Greg so you didn't
accl let's just let's just be real okay
that's a side quest you never
fin go back I'll bring you I'll never go
to gr that's just looks so
bad of pocket God Dam what's uh so like
why don't you feel like you've acclimate
like what do I mean what some yeah like
I'm still trying to figure out the town
hall to be honest okay yeah that's don't
worry that's something you'll never
figure out that's part of the
acclamation process figed out fig out
yeah the day you'll remember it is when
you're going to go collect your pensions
like that's the day you'll figure it out
yeah there's still news that I'm like oh
I have to do that and I need this paper
yeah so yeah you know what do you have
the my number card do you have that no
and why would I I don't get it the [__]
is that it's basically like so there are
benefits to it it's like a social
security card Japan what's wrong with my
actual card uh so SL no the z z it's
different it's different so the
basically because Japan is they realize
we're like huh guys we' [__] up here
we have so many different things all on
different paper and computer systems
that are not joining over why don't we
make one card that is allows you to
access all of them in one go oh and so
they have this they made this system but
a lot of old people didn't want to do it
because they're like I don't want the
government have more my [__]
information so a lot of people didn't do
it but uh there are benefits to it which
you can do which are one thing that I
absolutely love if you ever need to
print off documents or documents you
need to go to the City Hall to get you
can print them off at the com with this
car you have to do show you my number
card they SC it's like it's like a
printer it's on the printer there an
attachment on the printer you put it on
so if you ever need to get like tax
documents you don't need to go to the
City Hall you can just go to a printer
and go through the options and get all
the you need to print yeah and like the
jum H is that what it's called that the
resident yeah you can get that as well
from the printer so it's like realize
you were supposed to go to the town hall
for that yeah I haven't even got to I
got the one right and it's this
beautiful sotif for it and you they're
like oh can we see it and then they take
it and I'm like no oh yeah they yeah you
can't copy it they take it yeah I didn't
realize you're supposed to go to the
town hall to get new you to pay $4 for
them to print this [__] thing off I
don't know why and it's on some very
special paper with the biggest QR code
I've ever seen on the B it looks like a
mess uh yeah it's very annoying though
but just doing anything in the town hall
is never fun and and never gets easy all
right so I'm not alone there at least no
no no you you'll never feel wel kind
it's kind of like the DMV of Japan the
DMV in Japan is also bad well it depends
on which one you go to it's it depends
on the branch but every town hall
experience I've had is that I've had to
wait at least like even if it's like
super empty you book out your morning
and afternoon yeah basically you you
waste half of a day doing it yeah have
you renewed your license yet in Japan uh
which which one the driving license oh
that place yeah no I don't need to do
that yet but okay when you that place
you have to do a 2hour lecture no I saw
that [__] that I remember see you do you
just sit in a 2hour lecture of them
talking it's like a really old guy just
pointing at sign saying don't Drunk and
Drive don't don't don't drive too fast
on snow two hours and then you just get
to leave and you get your license it's
ridiculous so point I heard they had
like I don't know if this is true but I
heard they had like a bunch of
foreigners crashing cars in the videos
uh I I didn't see a video it was a
presentation but it's like some weird
propaganda yeah I don't know I was like
what the [__] the worst place in Japan
is where you have to reapply for the
Visa oh the immigration that's like hell
on Earth because they it's like also in
like the worst parts of Tokyo and
there's nothing around there's like no
stop shops there's no [__] train
station near it cargo after cargo like
where the [__] am I what is this I
didn't know there were sketchy places in
Tokyo like yeah that place is [__] and
then got next to like old dangerous
chemical plants like yeah you see people
scribbling like I hate Japan on like the
on the tables and [__] like so
depressing dude Jesus the town hall is
great though they're super friendly the
what the town hall actually Town Hall
yeah H it depends I guess you got a
lucky Town Hall yeah Town Hall Lucky
Town H Lucky Spa the one I live at now
is nice shiny Town Hall well the one
that the one that we used to live at was
a major major area in Sait so it was it
was a like [__] like 12
stories but the one I love it now is
really small and it's there's no one
ever this there's no lines and I'm like
yes the small ones are way better than
the massive ones for sure was fun I do
prefer it now it's way more chill so see
I feel like you have acclim knowing the
fact that like you're going to the
immigration office going to the town
hall getting documents is all the
biggest pain house in the world that I
would call that acclamation God there a
Japanese not have anything better to do
they filling papers all day like God
damn you are finding out no they do not
have anything jaan's economy could soar
through the sky stop by yeah and like
also everything's always different so if
you need to if you change your dress
right you need to go to the new town
hall and tell them that you change dress
which can be a little bit of a joke no
no you first have to go to your old town
hall to break up you got to break up you
got to break up with your old girlfriend
to get with your new girlfriend and then
and then oh wouldn't it be great I don't
know if my driving license could also be
updated in the same town hall no you
have to go to the police station to then
change on the back of your uh your
driving license to get them to put the
new address why the police station
because the police station manages all
the driving licenses which is separate
but why wouldn't you put it all in one
why do I have to go to two separate
[__] places to do this it's
ridiculous what does it say you've just
Googled flying cars or we would be we
would be driving in these if they all
had it all in one system they want to
put this for 2025 or Saka has like this
bump up gu they like a big this is a
helicopter dude that is a helicopter but
but the thing is they probably won't
make it because there's too much like
legalities to go through it's just a
it's a giant drone this just a big drone
I'm going to be so pissed if flying cars
come out like right after I die or
something just get a helicopter do we do
we want flying cars yes I mean cuz he
hates traffic who does it it's going to
be flying car traffic I don't mind
traffic what the [__] actually no that's
that's that's the weird wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait okay
listen listen da why you tell me to cut
through all of
it we were in a rush okay that's
different like daily traffic you know 5
10 minutes traffic it's slowed down for
maybe five minutes I don't give a [__]
about that if it's like an hour jam and
I'm stuck yeah that [__] sucks but
like this guy this one car stops in
front of him he's
like like but internally
yes but on the outside I'm a good person
I I I I can I can feel when you miss the
red light like you're the last car to
miss the red light I can feel your blood
pressure Rising do do you like driving
yeah yeah I drive here I love it driving
in Japan is fun I do like driving in
Japan a lot of people you know I think
one thing that is massively underrated
is driving in Japan because a lot of
people you know the trains are amazing
and definitely do use them that does
feel like pay to win yeah everyone
everyone takes public service so the
roads are all clear it's great it's
great because there's so many there's so
many cool areas of can and so many cool
things that you just cannot access
without a car Def and I think you know
if you if you don't mind driving
definitely do it if you you know maybe
like second or third trip in Japan look
into it it's it's really fun just don't
drive in Tokyo cuz that's a nightmare
it's not even that bad it's not even
that bad London is so much worse yeah oh
I've I wouldn't even like wish that upon
my worst
enemy I got my [__] I got my license in
London he [__] awful yeah he was like
okay so this this Junction is a funny
one um it's a it's a reverse roundabout
with a one-way system uh and if you go
into the car you get executed by a 1930s
law I'm like what what the [__] is this
like the road's not even paved he's like
yeah that's a feature and then the
random taxes you get if you're too big
of a vehicle in a certain Road or
something I don't know how it works I
just got a
bill same here or like taking some kind
of roads and there's a congestion charge
I didn't know that tolls in the UK what
the [__] you have to go through the toll
and then go home after go online yeah
and then say hey I was on the toll I'll
pay it with my credit card who thought
of that system yeah and if you don't pay
it you get because you know maybe you're
going to meet your family you forget to
you know you forget about it CU I'm my
first thought is is like I want to pay
this bill uh you forget about it you get
fined out the ass for being late why
would you not just like that that's like
going to a restaurant and you having to
pay once you got home I think I think
cuz they want to fine you they want to
get fines cuz that they can so much
money I I mean it's more like efficient
cuz you don't have like a like you know
a gate or Tollgate where people like
lined up still [__] slow but yeah
it's still [__] slow but so many
times I've had a toll and I didn't know
I needed to pay until I got back and
they were like you are late and you have
to pay 00
uh because I saw like one sign that says
you need to pay and I was like well I
I've already D driven past it so I don't
know any of the details I needed to and
you're driving it's not like you can
write down a note like on your phone or
some like yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah it's kind of dumb where in Japan
they just have the ETC card which is
really nice yeah Rock up that is nice
that is very nice that just sounds like
a scam it a scam it totally SC [__] up
every [__] tall is a scam oh damn
it's kind of like American Healthcare
like after you're done like here's the
bill by the way
yeah do Caravan don't worry about it you
owe us three limbs you were in a coma
and the interest was
crazy be started on inflation God damn
have you had a lot of time to travel
around Japan now uh not that much you've
been traveling a bit in yeah we went on
a trip with bej our first Trad went too
and
atami it was really good really enjoyed
it ni to finally be able to travel with
the baby as well even though it was hard
everything takes like 3 hours longer
than you should but no it's good it's
really fun uh those places are good we
went up the volcano thing yeah yeah
beautiful Fuji is one with the black
eggs like the onset oh no that's
that's to scam by is close yeah I don't
scam it is close yeah same prefix I mean
that area is all really nice yeah we
haven't gone far though like I think
furthest we went was Ula so yeah you
haven't gone to kushu yet no oh kushu
and
my we were planning to go but we were
like that's too far with the baby yeah
yeah I mean for kushu it's it's kind of
tough cuz it's like and and Hokkaido too
it's like five hours train or 2our
flight but then flights suck so and
you're like h i don't they defin these
flights not good I me no flights are
good I mean it's better than normal but
it's still still miserable okay it's
like a flight sucks and if you go with
shinin you can only go to like the very
like beginning of Q and the rest of it
is all cover no no no you you can the sh
goes the way to um um uh Kashima does it
yeah I thought it stops in uh [__] H
you have to tr you have to change and
then there's another bullet train that
goes all the way down to karashima I did
not know that and there's one that goes
to Nagasaki they have their own
completely own bullet train it's
completely different design it's really
cool they've got like a wood version I
did not know that it's really cool um
shine yeah goes to yeah wow I did not
know that show that can you can you show
the uh the wooden shinen you no no no
it's it's been around for a while really
oh [__] cuz my understanding of shon s
is you could only go as far as okay
um just like
has interior wooden bullet trains yeah
there's like one that has like a really
beautiful oh
[__] uh oh it's a I didn't know that was
a shinan no no no it's one of them maybe
it is maybe I got it wrong there is one
that's really nice and K also has the
seven seven C this extremely luxury
classical they know how to make it fancy
they make a lot of things fancy I was
going to say with how fast the Shen
content is going do you want it to be
built out of woods it's just no no sorry
like the inside they have like a little
wood okay when I when I saw wood was
like what the friction of the air bur in
Flames just
like it's like Shing gunon ghost wooden
sh G bad idea just SP just flying
everywhere plastic she well I guess yeah
they got their own little weird one look
at that it's got like an interior
Japan's train culture is just on another
level yeah I can see why TR exist man
the middle one yeah I didn't know that
was a thing until one TR yeah no no
before it they're insane yeah there's no
talk everything in Japan but definitely
one for trains oh that's a render
Jesus well that's not what I look like
have you guys ridden the not the
business but the first C inan can in
yeah the grand class Grand class it's so
good I've still never done never can
never go back grand class it's so good
it's so good cuz it's like a it's like
an extra 30 bucks on top of the green so
I guess normal it' be like an extra 50
bucks is this only for certain Shin
consense only for ones that go north oh
so yeah so Jr East and West are
separated and it's only uh Jr East that
that has the new cars the Jr cuz even
the green cars so there's three classes
in you normal green and Grand but uh the
one that goes to Oraka only has green
and normal and the green one is a lot
older and it's not as nice and then even
if the you go uh East or North uh the
green is really nice as well a lot more
spacious a lot nicer but the grand class
is amazing and it's like an extra 30
bucks it's quiet and you get you get
unlimited beverages any beverage you
want you get food you get snacks as and
you get your own personal service it's
more sound isolated yes yes way quieter
and fully reclining chair I might have
to it's so don't sleep on it the problem
is that most tourists don't do it
because you can't you can't get the um
you can't use the rail pass on it right
and it chinon is already quite expensive
um so you add on an extra so C like the
longer you go the more it costs but then
you get more value out of it so it's
worth it it's it's definitely worth it I
took it I took it yesterday from uh oh
Fancy no which is a three hour I get
fancy sometimes three-hour bull train I
think it was a lot of time I think it
was niman yeah for the ticket and I
think the regular is uh so two uh so
20,000 yen and the is 12,000 okay so
it's I guess it's like 8,000 Yen more
which is what 50 bucks yeah but I think
the amount of coffee and tea I drank
was they have an espresso machine that's
the important thing oh they make it all
fresh I don't think it's espresso
machine like four over but it's all
really good and they give you these
chocolates these little sea salt
chocolates I get chocolates well it's
cuz they don't like you
okay okay it's it's the free you didn't
blink when you let them in yeah yeah you
didn't do full blinks I need get a snack
you get snacks you do yeah you get like
a it's really really nice what's your
like bucket list right now of like
places you want to visit next hokido for
sure yeah yeah I was I was kind of
pissed I missed out last year cuz all of
a sudden everyone was in hokido I think
you were in hokido Chris was in Ido Mar
was like I'm going to Ido with my friend
I'm like cool I'll just stay
here it's it's just fun the snow
festival or something like that yeah the
snow I actually didn't like the snow
Festival much I heard that good last
year it was it was it was okay like the
stuff's really impressive but you kind
of see one and you're like this is
really cool it's really impressive and
then you have to like waddle through so
many people that's never fun and then
you're like okay I got see another one
let's wad again more busy because it's
been a while since it was over open
because of co uh yeah absolutely it was
delayed for like two years yeah exactly
and I mean it's definitely like amazing
to look at but I wouldn't plan a trip to
go see it because I just think that you
it's so hard to do anything on that
period it's there all the restaurants
are full uh all the hotels are really
expensive it's it's okay but I feel like
sapora is just better for The Vibes in
general like go go for the city not for
the snow Festival like it's such a cool
City I mean that area is just so cool in
general [__] so much to do uh I
always thought the snow Festival would
just be like a nice little extra if I
got to experience it even like the
country side of H is dope as [__] it's
some of the most beautiful scenery I've
ever seen in Japan my favorite ice cream
place in the world is in Hokkaido my
favorite soup curry place in the world
me
too the goat and they're right next to
each other 30 minut Drive they they're
not right 30 minut drive it's yeah it's
like 2 but it's worth it because you eat
the amazing soup carry you're so full
you're like God I'm so full I wish I had
ice cream let's drive 30 minutes to get
ice cream it's so good iceam totally
it's this it's this Farm uh and in they
open winter and and spring and both both
times it looks really beautiful because
and it's uh right um it's got a
beautiful view of Mount yote um and so
you can have this amazingly homemade
gelato uh and then have like a coffee
with the with the milk from the farm
everything milk you get like processed
please ask me for the photo I'll dude
we've said this on the podcast in the
Pasto has just likeed F God your food
okay I'm actually not a fan of their
milk uh we get your crunch
gun it's it's just way too [__] heavy
I don't I don't I don't drink the milk
straight I have it in things like the
butter it's amazing okay it's amazing
but like I remember like every staying
in like every hotel in Hokkaido uh they
have like they give you like the H and
then for breakfast and I take like two
sips and I'm like I'm not even hungry
anymore this is this is just like
drinking cream it's one step away from
your well it's like it's like 400
calories of [__] yeah that's all I need
baby definitely recommend H some
beautiful really really
beautiful choose like fun Vibes where
everyone's really happy and really chill
and everyone wants to chat Hokkaido is
more like you go for like an amazing in
kind of kind of chill vacation what are
you giggling
about what are you
[__] [__] high school again
shaking
toes my God sorry you were saying I'm
just [__] it's fine I gu I'll go my own
I'll I'll [__] myself I'll play foot
myself it's fine I can I can I can reach
I can I can reach down where are you all
I don't know where you is that you is
that you or is that Felix I don't know
who's this am I touching is it joeyy
fcking godamn it I'm fing with Joey
again I take all the love you didn't
smile at all oh yeah somehow Japan is
the aside from my home country the
easiest place I have to uh get away with
the name I have normally people would
just look at my name and just start
having a panic attack so Japanese people
get it right yeah cuz it's Mano which is
like all you know Japanese Katakana
sound I've started booking restaurants
under a Japanese name cuz I'm so of like
who are
you I want to know which surname you
decided to
pick what name what Le name have you
decided to pick I I just chose
Tanaka because I realized I realized
especially especially when uh cuz
sometimes I would call up and when I
would say my everything would be going
smoothly I'd be like I want to reserve
you we got an opening I got this and
then I'd be like oh here my name they're
like huh it's just like an awkward like
five minutes I'm like I'm just going to
say this [__] name and then when I
turn up because it doesn't matter
there's no iding I just say this I just
find a [__] hilarious that you book
under Mr Tanaka and then you rock up to
the [__] restaurant you're like uh oh
they always they always go like
huh yeah t same with me so it's fine
trust me this I I I know this sounds bad
but it works it genuinely works that's a
good idea I'll be Tanaka especially if
you call if you if you're calling it
definitely helps cuz like you can I feel
like I'm I'm nailing this conversation
going perfect and they get to the name
I'm like yeah they're
like for for a while I just kept saying
Conan like k k I was like oh they'll
know that because I'd say Conor and they
like K and they're like I don't know I
don't know the [__] anyone know this guy
saying your name is so simple though
yeah I I know I'd be like Kanan they're
like like Kanan oh oh
con I know
con you know I in Japan you have to be
so specific when when you write down the
name for the bank
oh I had to read out my entire name
middle name like Felix Arvid ol
shellberg over the phone no no you have
to do it the last name first yeah first
name then middle yeah it makes no
[__] sense but that was a nightmare
to spell out over the phone that's the
worst thing ever and of course it was
wrong so they call again and have to do
the whole [__] thing again it's not
my [__] problem you I was like I just
email it to you and they're like no well
no that was the worst part cuz one time
I had a fraud detection didn't call up I
was sending myself money uh and they
were like we need to make sure it's not
fraud I was like why of course like it
says my name but they do that in UK too
yeah yeah and he was like you know uh he
because he was speaking English to me it
was It was kind of to the point where I
was like I think I think I think my
Japanese which is bad is better than his
English like that he's like you know LLY
Russia
bad and I was like what do you you
always say that my banker said it too no
way really he was like fraud must check
I was like Russia bad I was like what
are you like I'm not russan what are you
talking about I I got no Russian any so
uh and then he's like what's your email
and so and I'm reading out this email to
him and it's like a 9-h hour process of
me going c b d and he's like D no no no
[__] Z he's like what this I'm like no
and then we get to the end and then it's
do UK because I'm UK and he's like I
don't know what the [__] that is I
put.com
no through all of
way my official documents on some bills
that I pay are just have misspellings as
well like my my inst and I haven't
gotten it changed yet because I've been
putting it off even though I definitely
should get it changed verying over you
uh but yeah my do do do do foreign
immigrants have this problem when they
come to the like UK or America they're
like ah [__] I misspell my name from
Brian to Bryant do you know what I don't
understand you're Bob now Brian's too
hard do you know I don't understand so
on my Internet bill so when I signed up
for my internet I had to spell my name
spell it again but also there was this
process where I had to scan my ID card
and send it to them for them to like you
know double check that I am a real
person and I'm like there is absolutely
no way I could [__] they could [__] this
up and I get my Internet bill back and
it still to this day says Grant I do not
know how they [__] that
up they they're in on it they're in on
it like just like and I can't be
bothered to change it as well because it
was like such a you you you know when
you have like to change your name it's
just a 5 minute process turned into an
hour long oh no no no there's there's
such thing as a [__] five minute
process in Japan nothing is a 5 minute
process it's it's [__] annoying
that's the worst part for sure so that's
you know so I think you're fully
acclimated now you just need to do a
little bit more yeah if you can relate
to all these know the me have you had
your bank like close your bank account
as your Visa is renewing have you had
that happen no so the bank will send
every time I'm about to Vis Vis they'll
be like hey your Vis coming out they
don't close it they freeze it right they
freeze it but the thing is is that the
bastards they freeze it before your
visas run out right they'll freeze it
like a few days before which I think is
so [__] cruel yeah why do they do
this at least free okay I can understand
if you freeze it when it expires I'm
like okay I get it you want to you want
to [__] be strict on this law I got
it you're right but a few days before
come on man I still got [__] going I
still got time why you leaving the last
minute to get your I I'm not but
sometimes what happens is that what
happened last time is that uh when I was
renewing my Visa they um the immigration
just said we like like hey we want like
another month to go over it we just want
to [__] with you a little bit yeah I was
like we went another month and I was
like what but my bank so so the I had to
go to my bank and like explain and it
was like an hour and a half thing where
I'm like no I'm definitely getting it I
promise but I I have this thing in my
password that says I'm here for another
month so can you let me have it and
they're like they go back they always go
they always go back and forth with the
manager and it's like what is it can you
just come over here and help me with
this please come on man I'm I'm trying
to do stuff today the manager cannot
talk to Mere
peasants I must go through someone
that's my that's the worst thing I think
about Japan and like service industry is
that when when you have a problem you
can't just talk to someone who knows the
they always have to keep going back and
forth with someone who knows and it's
like why so why do they freeze it like
what's the reason I think it's I'm not
sure I think the UK doesn't close it
immediately I think there's a there's a
window I'm not sure I think it's some
kind of their justification of like you
know you've lost your Visa you you know
we don't want to well a great man once
said Russia bad must check for fraud
yeah maybe that's they'll call me up
I'll be like why is it frozen he's like
Russia
bad that's all I got to say that's
literally what he said I I just remember
being on the train platform waiting and
he's in my ear says that and I just
burst out laughing I'm like no way he
just said that it's probably how we
sound like in Japanese I sound way worse
Russ uh let's see what's
this yeah it's we we get treated with
the we get treated with the the past
crimes and the fraud fraudsters yeah I
do for being foreign one thing uh one
thing I wanted to ask uh which is
something that I guess I've thought
about
uh which is you know when I when I
eventually decide to be a dad now with
trash he's thinking about it now with
trash taste now now with trash taste
there is just so much content on me out
there and it's always going to be out
there and I what are you implying no
okay how you how do you feel what are
you
actually okay okay Bon comes in he's
like da what is apology
video did Dad do bad
no you
weren why was that the first video you
out of the thousands of videos I have I
try to block all of it no because I
think YouTubers are getting to that
point now where there I think there are
some YouTubers who kids that are getting
old enough to have started to become old
enough to really watch and understand
because there's never been a I don't I
think the oldest YouTuber kids I can
think of that like were growing up after
the YouTube and all that stuff I think
like I don't know like Phil to Franco or
something I don't know also it's just
weird to me because you think about you
know think about your own parents and
you have no kind of bearing of what they
were like when no [__] clue yeah yeah
yeah you hear stories and it's almost
like alien you hear a story from like an
aunt or an uncle about how oh your your
parents were like this and you're like
this that's that's that's a fake person
it's actually smart though cuz you're
preloading like you know those iPad kids
it's like yeah my kid's an iPad kid but
he only watches
dad he's i' I've curated playlist of the
greatest hits to babysit to babysit my
son it's not weird he watches only
me that's pretty good actually would
that
be psychopatic you could probably you
could probably convince your kid long
enough to be like no no this his dad
talking to something to boy also because
it's like you get the ad R for it's just
culating it's going in the F son my kid
is making me so much Bang from just
watching my playlist also you can
discipline your kid for playing too many
video games ever again cuz they could
just they could just like they just load
up the re being
like I calculated how many hours you
know okay okay uh just while because I'm
going to forget if I don't say this
remember that one time well I don't
remember the last podcast I brought up
that you sang Take On Me Yeah in in
Sweden we did it 3 2 one withing
away I don't know what I to say I'll say
any another
day
sh take oh we did it yeah did oh my
[__] God I told you not to no it was
great show in Sweden we did a
Justice Take On Me in front of the it
was great it was great it was great it
was great yeah it was great is there in
any cringe compilations how can I see
this no it was in the win compilations
by fail army soone was mine so was mine
no it wasn't son's going to see that and
be like it's a it's a fun song to sing
it was it wasn't the same cuz there
wasn't like the shot of just the crowd
having the Thousand Islands there they
didn't me
dirty that was that was the first Ninja
moment you know when he's like why we
I'm not seeing enough movement okay we
don't need to bring up this will not see
these videos that will not be in the Cur
playlist
yeah whenever VI something bad and
you're like scolding him you'll just be
like don't T I have the
receip just pull the iPad God I just
realized yeah there's too much well I
mean I think it's fun too like we're
that'll be really fun I think yeah that
be cool and we're doing the Vlogs now
like I don't have any videos of me as a
kid so I have no idea what it was like
so I think it'll be fun to to watch that
kind of stuff yeah for sure yeah because
the the you did you have those like
family photo books when you were growing
up oh totally yeah and there you could
you could kind of figure out roughly
what was going on but it feels so feels
so cool looking at like just a still of
of yeah watch those forever I have a
shitload of like family videos cuz my
really I I didn't have any it' be so
cool I kind of wish that like I think
it'd be so cool for my kid to see me
like 20 just doing my thing be my it's
painful to watch yeah but it'd be cool
dude I'd love to see my dad
so sick like I I kind of feel like that
secondhand embarrassment of like damn I
was cringe as [__] like when whenever I
look at some of these videos cuz I'm
just like N I wouldn't I I wouldn't say
that like I think you know you you'll
you'll like you know if you have a good
relationship with your dad you'll love
your dad and you'll be like man it's so
[__] cool just seeing my dad hold no
my my parents use it to roast the [__]
out of me there are two types of memory
keeping want to to [__] someone over
whenever whenever my dad puts on like a
family video of me and my sister like
you know I'm like like four years old 5
years old that's just cute yeah no like
my mom is sitting there being like oh
look at you you're so cute my dad's like
no look at you your balls haven't
dropped yet your little
[__] bro he's roasting a [__] how old
are youting a todler bro can't fight
back why is he roasting toddlers son you
sound like a squirrel puber at four your
dad your dad was 100% the kind of dad
that when you all started doing like
sports he was like [__] Joey [__]
why you winning [__] you [__] yeah it's
like you lost that's
cringe that's the dad I strive to be oh
my like the one family uh video I
remember is like my dad trying to like
my dad taking me to and my parents
taking me to the playground yeah and my
mom just lets me play around and stuff
and my dad's like the [__] the
[__] grind set guy he's like I get on
the monkey bars and I give up halfway
and he's like going again really he like
we don't quit in this house again don't
don't quit halfway through and I go and
again give up and he's like no I'm going
to pick you up and you're going to learn
how to do these monkey balls oh really
yeah that's awesome yeah you find that
helpful I too young to say I was too
young okay but I just mean in General
trying to understand what's the good
parenting talken
please I feel like letting them learn a
little bit on their own is a good way
because I remember I one of the reasons
why I how long how old were you guys
when he learned how to ride a bike I
was six think I just unlocked a memory I
remember I don't remember being being in
my driveway and doing it when I was like
I feel like I taught myself I don't
remember really oh [__] did you ever
have like the training wheel phase or I
did yeah of course yeah [__] tore it
up yeah so like my when my dad tried to
teach me how to ride a bike uh he just
completely skipped the training wheel
stage he was just like he was just like
get good and riding is a
it was like son you just got to grind it
out if you fall over don't worry just
get up and just stop being a [__]
[__] the wheels off the parent goes
with the kid right so they're holding it
in case they're like yeah my dad used to
like like hold the back of the bike and
then he'd be like all right I'm going to
let go and I'm like Dad please don't and
when you do it anyway and then yeah i'
get fall you fall and then you get hurt
you cry you try again and then
eventually do it yeah I think that's
just Asian Dad I think this just an
Asian Dad got scar here
last I think my parents were just like
please stop cuz I just kept doing dumb
[__] I used to like you know I would see
a bump and I'm like I'm going to
jump no I was I was too much of a [__]
to do stuff like that I just had no
sense of fear as a kid and then I got it
when I fell really badly one time and I
was like 15 everyone's going to learn
somehow I was like oh [__] this is scary
[__] around and found out this is
[__] scary like it really [__]
hurt Christ yeah that's that's how all
those Red Bull [__] athlete people
become those crazy people they just like
they they just don't get they just don't
get hurt for a long enough of a time
until they're an adult and then they
they they can't learn it now they're
like all right I'll break my arm or
they're like oh well it didn't kill me
so I guess I'll I can do it again yeah
those Red Bull sponsorships pay too good
I can't CH back now I got to do the free
running championship and the
slang I know sometimes I see how far the
Adrenaline Junkies go and I'm like how I
kind of get it you I love you have a
little bit of that you have a little bit
of that but there's a certain moment
where like bungee jumping I I would have
been doing love to do that all day that
was so fun hell I would never do that
would you do like I don't know what the
actual name is but the one where you
just jump off a [__] cliff with
aeing oh with a with a a paragliding say
really bad oh that that just seems like
instant death paragliding I really want
what I really want to do that my
intrusive thoughts would take over like
why I just you have a guy who steers it
for you cuz you you can't you mean the
squirrel suit thing right that looks
[__] sick I want I want to do that
looks so
fun I got train I got a train I got a
train it looks cool but when I'm not
doing it I would GL if you told me like
Conor we could hook it up you can go and
learn how to do it I'd love to that' be
F what I've always wanted to know is how
do you learn how to do something like
this because presumably it's an activity
if you [__] up once well it's like
skydiving right you have to do x amount
of hours like tandem with a professional
and like really like learn how to do it
you have do a lot of hours like L of
these jobs like like like cave diving
requires hundreds of hours like of
experience that's how a lot of them
manage so it's just you just have to be
a hobby and do it with an instructor a
lot yeah it's really really you have to
really really be dedicated to it um but
obviously PS pretty well when you do it
when you do get certified or whatever cu
no one else is [__] I think the most
extreme thing I would attempt to learn
or attempt to do a scuba diving I really
want to go scuba diving but that's not
it's kind of it's super dangerous pretty
[__] danger yeah it depends how deep
you go but how deep are we talking even
going like 40 m is really really like
that doesn't sound much that sounds like
nothing 40 M is so much that's so d i
stand
up that's nothing yeah at which at which
point does sunlight stop penetrating
like it's like 5 m nah yes well even
like even like free diving without okay
first of all you first of all with with
scuba diving at like 40 m you have to
start decompressing and that's the scary
part you just sit there in the water for
like an hour yeah you can't you can't
just you can't just it people do and
they die that's beta [__] skill you
it uh I'll Google the okay you while you
Google cuz I've done in the Philippines
I did the thing where like you put on
that like water uh hel I saw that on
your vog and then you you go to that was
10 m okay and that was a lot on your
body oh really and it doesn't feel like
like you look up and it's like oh I'm
not even that far from the surface but
you just you feel that pressure as
you're going down like your body just
gets so heavy and I'm like I can't
imagine going double that first 10 m
water already absorbs more than 50% of
visible light that's at 10 m yeah deps
below 1,000 M receive no light from the
surface whatsoever you said 40 for the
we said 40 so [__] idiots but the
amount of I'm saying it's already it's
at 40 m I think it's already really
[__] dark yeah it gets in the water
but there's so much [__] in the water
like dirt and stuff you're not going to
be able to see anything I don't want to
sco it
there well yeah cuz it's like the the
amount of just the amount it's not even
the sunlight thing or anything it's just
the amount of pressure on your body at
40 M is so much for your body that if
you immediately like just come up to the
surface you get you get [__] up this
seems like the kind of thing I have no
knowledge of and that's why I'm just
like that seems silly just float yeah
just hold your breath on what's a big
deal just swim up just swim up I'm
trying to find how long you'd have to
wait uh to I don't know how you you'd be
waiting which is the scariest part
because you're like what if something
goes wrong and you know you need to
decompress the it says according to some
sources the theoretical limit of human
body pressure underwater is 1,000 M
which is 100 atmospheres of pressure
that's the theoretical limit that's the
theoretical limit I me people people
dive to like hundred something yeah um
which is crazy and that's still insane
yeah well the reason why I think you can
dive off of breath way deeper and come
back up no issues than you can if you
use the tank M cuz the tank uses
different us it uses like a a nitrogen
uh mix uh not nitrogen um 60 M some I
don't know what what's in a scuba diving
tank you it's it's like a mix between
it's a very concentrated thing that
helps decompress you not to compress you
like keep you your head not hurting
while you're diving 79% nitrogen 21% off
yes nitrogen okay was right it's like a
nit and so then when you're coming up
the the you'd have like bubbles in your
blood otherwise Cal too fast they [__]
you yeah it's really [__] scary yeah
your blood boils what similar hardcore
you would do I don't [__] a
sheep I would do
like sorry sorry sry that's just in your
bloodline sorry sorry sorry sorry S I
feel you want to go skydiving right I I
want to do skydiving let's do skydiving
I could do like jumping off stuff at a
depending on you do BU jumping yeah I
would do jump I feel like I judge you
Joey but I I yeah I'm not doing anything
you want do BU jumping no dude it's so
fun seen the videos I wouldn't do bungee
jumping but I would do skydiving wait
what I do not skying [__] because to me
like it my my like whole thing of it is
I am more scared of like the awkward
height than I am like the really really
high heights you know what I mean I I
kind of yeah I kind of understand like
I'm okay like people when people are
like afraid of heights right like
there's lots of different levels I feel
like I'm Not Afraid going on like an
airplane like even though you're a lot
higher right but I get the most nervous
the most nervous I get with Heights is
when you're like looking over looking
over like a 10 story building dude it's
so fun though that's I get and like do
you get that voice in your head to say
it would be cool to jump no my in my
head is that just me no in my head no in
my head I'm just like I better step away
before someone PES that's what's so good
about Bunch jumping is that you get that
voice and you're like let's do it and
then you get like you get this beautiful
moment where for about a second you are
just speeding up weightlessness and
there's not you feel nothing but just
[__] the ground rushing towards you
it's so cool that sounds terrible no
it's amazing it's such a rush yeah but
like I've like that that's amazing I
want to it's so fun and then and then
you get the fun part of the bungee where
you get to fly it's really fun just a
scene from inception right that's how
you that's how you get the kick you just
get jolted for way but like to me
skydiving is way less scary than bungee
jumping for I think it's actually I
think skyd is also safer than bungee
jumping I would I think pretty sure
there's more deaths in bung jump
heard well a lot of the places where you
can bunge jump um uh not they're the
best Rocky Ravines well it's it's kind
of like some dude and his cousin who
bought a bungee cord and were're like
let's do it yeah I would trust Japan
with bu bunge jumping yeah Japan is the
one place I was like I I'll definitely
do bungee jumping here I I would trust
any other but also like another big
thing is that you know if okay worst
case scenario something goes wrong in
skydiving versus something go goes wrong
in bungee jumping I feel like they're
both bad they're both F they're both bad
but I feel like at the height you're
jumping at skydiving you're you're just
like it's it's just instant death
actually no it's not is it not no
because terminal velocity so there's at
a certain point you reach the max speed
you could go which is like I think it's
how many stories is it can you go what
is Max velocity for falling off a
building I think it's like uh 20 stories
or something so it's like this you
jumping from like 50,000 the same for
your body Landing as jumping from like
uh we'll find out now
um hey and if you land in
trees all right if you land in trees
yeah but assuming like open field just
going to give up yeah yeah I I feel less
stressed knowing that I have I can do
nothing to save myself oras if I'm like
you got to try when if if I'm jumping
off a cliff I'm like well it's going to
be like the worst pain in my life but
let's just break my legs and most my
back someone says some dude on a forum
says you'd reach terminal Voss in about
4 and a half seconds of folding that's
pretty quick second so four half let's
say that guy's right which you might
it's still pretty fast uh yeah it's very
yeah but like it's you're saying like
that's like M an hour it says yeah so
that's like this you know you jumping
from a big building would have the same
effect on your body when you land is
jumping from a
50,000 right that makes sense so G you
would just find like concrete to fall on
or something you'd be like just want
this over I just just like just like
make it quick make it isn't your best if
there was a pool right next to did you
not land in the pool no no you die if
you hit the pool oh [__] cuz the surface
tension of the water pool what where
should you land then uh you should land
on the ground and spread out your body
take the guarantee full damage death is
that like the elevator thing where
you're just supposed to lay down yeah
because your your all the force is being
distributed across your body I heard you
just was Landing trees that's all I know
I think trees is good because you have a
chance of like hitting a bunch and
stumbling before you if you're in like
do or is that just in cartoons well I
think if you can any way you can kind of
kill the speed before you land as good
even if it hurts a [__] T like someone
was it that woman in the gorilla suit
have survived she survived with the
gorilla suit when her parachute didn't
I'm not kidding Google this gorilla suit
gorilla suit save skydiver type that in
that's so F she was wear it was a
charity skydiving event I believe and
she jumps out with this gorilla
suit uh and uh I think Colorado's one on
Sky uh be that one I think it was people
do live but G you would just fall in
with like same with like aanes like
people who grab onto like debris or
something really help like that
increases your chances massively of
surviving okay but here's the thing
hypothetical situation do you try to
survive in that
situation you just am I the only one
who's just like yeah I guess I guess my
time has come you're too content with
dying you just want to die God it sounds
like you want okay okay if if you're in
like if you're in like a p uh plane CR
do you like just you know go to the
brace position bra position all the way
if there's if there's a one shot chance
I can survive awesome I'm taking look
around everyone doing the braak and
you're like what a [__] is stands
up
like i' be like guys well it's been a
good run let me just please that's the
only
time I I I never I never I've never
smoked like cigarettes but the one time
I think I would smoke a cigarette as if
I know I'm about to die like all right
well [__] it who's going to
lie did you feel like an appropriate
response to diey you know I had a moment
where I was trying to find like what to
do in all these like hypothetical
scenarios and it was so irritating
trying to find the answers cuz you it's
like yeah you're probably [__] because
even if you survive a plane crash right
odds are you're flying over the ocean
yes which makes it immediately [__]
impossible difficulty you're just done
and then the question is in my head I'm
like do I have do I have it in me to
want to survive once I survive this
crash that's what I'm saying do I want
to go through the all people trying to
find me do I want to have to survive
this sounds like a [__] bullach I'm
going to this just sounds like too much
work I'd rather die instantly actually
you know what I'm on gun side now [__]
this damn just a [__] hustle isn't
that yeah I remember there was one where
it's like just reset the
server if you fall through ice yeah I
was like okay what do I do like
that could happen you walk in a ice Lake
you fall in what do you do they're like
oh grab your ice piics to pull yourself
up I'm like if I I clearly don't have
those in this scenario get your go go
[__] out machine and get the [__] out of
there I think you just would grab both
sides if you can hopefully and then well
you slay
out yeah get a leg in I don't know what
what do you do just cry I think you just
[__] at that point it's like have you
seen that video of the guy who's trying
to swim under the ice to the other side
cuz they put and the guy can't find it
and his friends are like slamming the
top like here you [__] that is
anxiety I feel like there are some life
or death situations that you know I feel
I could survive where do you draw the
line then where do you fire name name
name a life and death situation you
survive 100 out of 10 times like even
though even though it said like sence
says I won't I feel like I could just
Survive by just the ego of my own way of
thinking like what give me give me jump
jumping off a bridge
right okay what bridge like Golden Gate
Bridge gold Gate Bridge you survive you
no you don't survive I feel okay I feel
like you know what everyone tells me
surface tension is a thing but I feel
like wiggle your legs right before yeah
just just like if I have you know just
like make yourself into like a [__]
pencil or something I feel like I I get
I get it it's just like you you would
break your your arms or legs at best
that's that's what that's what science
says who trust science to me water go
splash that's what I'm saying right some
people believe in the I think it's a I
think it's a myth but they throw a like
a rock or something to break the Surak
but I think it's a myth I think it's
actually I think that was Prov in
MythBusters SS MythBusters episode yeah
okay yeah but I saw this guy who broke
recently broke the the highest freef
fall into water record can you this uh
it's like type in world record free fall
into
water it should come up have you ever
had this thought where if you were in
like a like a elevator that dropped if
you just jump at the last moment yeah
obviously that's the only logical thing
to do right right you definitely
survived that right you're supposed to
lay down that's what I learned but it's
that's not fun I'd rather just try
Jumping Jesus if it's frame perfect I
think I think it was you can get away
with it it's skish really angle angle
perfect and frame perfect just no no
one's just achieved it yet oh yeah 4
days ago you have to pause buffer as you
fall you fall 150 M hour I'll put it in
the group I'll put in the group higher
than that yeah Stronger Yeah I put I'll
put it in the group so you can show the
guys uh what is this your uh Googling
Corner this is the guy look at this look
at this free fall jum let's I want to
see gone do you reckon you survive this
all right send it to K how you get it on
I was a Norwegian um yeah of course it's
[__] of course it's nor they have
nothing to
do what do the swedes do what do they do
we play video games move to Japan play
video games leave Sweden that's why
there's so many swets online there's
nothing else to do
actually we have the same problem
whenever whenever I played Cod back in
the day there was always a Norwegian or
Scandinavian person that was just so
good at it and you're like [__] you
there's nothing else to do I don't know
I don't know how the [__] you got on
that tangent basically Okay g you're not
[__] surviving the no like I know I'm
not but I feel like I think you you feel
actually you know what I think I could
what the [__] is this a dumb idea
spreading well that's trash taste okay
make sure your kid does not watch Trash
T Joe what are you
surviving um kangaroo attack like what
what what what is something what is a
situation someone says is like dangerous
but you're like I think I think I could
come out of this oh bear attack a bear
attack I I think if a bear is right in
front of me I think I get out of it I
don't think I die I know you think that
I I don't know if the bad I don't know
if the bad thinks that I think that see
one thing you have to understand Conor
is that he's very uh like he has a lot
of confidence in things I've noticed
that I'm going to scream at this
[__] bear until he leaves me
alone
con different typ ofs BR I scream at all
of them well then you're D yeah I
Winn
win Conor's the [__] in a zombie
apocalypse who's like I'll begin the
Army go out and immediately dies guys I
got bit is it
bad zombies
though my K is still
good I'll be fine no I'd win I'd win I
ran so you could all
walk yeah would you survive the zombie
apocalypse survive the we've discussed
this so many times the conclusion we
came to what position would you be in
the zombie apocalypse like what what
would the stereotype what what
stereotype would you fall under I'll
just be the one cuz if I learn anything
from some movies or whatever it's just
like oh the real danger we see other
people all along and it's like yeah I'll
just stay away from other people Lane so
you'd be like the long you got to talk
to people you need to no well we have to
stick together why because what if you I
have all the provisions
okay what is this an OC where you have
everything you ever need in my head have
it odds you play too much Dead Rising
odds are you got some [__] poopy
diapers and some some cans of food and
you got nothing you're in Japan we got
no weapons we're done I'll throw my [__]
at the zombies that'll stop
them fin inconvenience the zomb oh oh
Jesus [__] I have the samurai swords
sliding through where are you getting
that do you do you own a samurai sword I
will not
disclose
he definitely do we'll see what happens
yeah he's he's already prepping don't
test
me all right [__] would that be a weapon
of choice samurai sword in Japan yeah
that's the dream he follows the code of
BU Kill the Zombies finally you just
chops him cleans the blood it's like
finally an excuse to pull this
out I can live out my wee dream you know
that would happen like around here oh
yeah if it breaks out in Japan it'll be
so sick yeah mean prime location what do
you mean Prime loc for what we like suck
blossoms and oh my God zombies nothing
beats nothing beats killing zombies
under the cherry blossoms I'll tell you
that
fellas double points for the Aesthetics
oh my Lord everything's better in
Japan Zombie Apocalypse Zombie
Apocalypse Zombie Apocalypse in
Japan okay they always do it in games
come on you know what I mean okay
there's got to be something there's got
to be something that's thee of guy to
like chop down a zombie and then do
the H
yeah what were you saying Sor there's
got to be something there's got to be
something that is not better in Japan or
is that Banks yeah objectively I guess
zombie apocalypse fixes all the bad
things about Japan sure work life
balance gone uh Town Hall Banks gone all
bad things so I guess maybe apocalypse
is what we
need then we know for real then we'll
really know truly the best that is true
that is true I'm I'm trying to think is
there is there any other like famous
apocalypse types out there or is it only
just like zombie apocalypse I guess like
nuclear maybe
oror meteor were done none none of them
we all done yeah none of them are like
fun to survive you know there's no
chance any there's no chance you know
what about like a Long Winter like a
winter That Never Ends o that' be fun
that's not fun I feel like even just Co
was bad enough I'm like [__] there's out
of no toilet I think if everywhere was
like blizzarding we'd be done everyone
would die very quickly you think so in
Japan yeah because like I don't think
you if it was constantly blizzarding I I
don't think you'd be able to keep the
roads clean yeah but I feel like Japan
that's that's the big issue yeah because
how can you how can you transport food
how can you how can you grow food uh
well that too but we we have we have a
lot of canned food that'll last a while
right we got to you Japan would figure
it out
like all right guys um everyone has to
take turns sacrificing their body uh for
cannibalism so you can buy this bag of
rice for uh two cup ramens like that'll
be the new that'll be the new that's you
know prison cup Ramen Ramen is currency
in prisons right yeah so I guess Japan
will become prison will'll be rich
Yes we finally be the W another better
thing oh my Lord if a meteor H strikes
would we all die yeah yeah but surely
some people live well depends on the
size medeor people have bunkers and [__]
right yeah people in bunkers would live
okay yeah you no but like you no but the
medeor where it hit if the if a direct I
get that but I just mean like okay let's
say where where is all Humanity gone
like no I think it's really hard to get
rid of all of humanity to to wipe out Mo
to wipe out most of humanity is
technically like easy but to wipe out
all of humanity will take a lot of
effort because some way somehow some
people can survive we are like cockes
yeah well I'm not going to
die what Mak say that well it seems like
you guys are giving up so I'll take the
opportunity to not
die our life force doesn't go into you
Felix that's not how it works I don't
know maybe it
does Goku you said some people would
live and you all give up so I'll give
okay first of all I didn't give up I
said we died cuz of [__] meteor
giving up we're not giving up I'm dead
cuz a giant space I'll a hole in the
ground I'll be prepared would you yeah
okay yeah that's a question would you
try and survive like during that kind of
Apocalypse yeah it' be
fun I would yeah be kind of I would
describe it as fun I okay I would
honestly Rish at the chance that my only
[__] thing I have to worry about is
getting food and water it's kind of nice
yeah but that's all I got to
do I I don't got I don't got to do taxes
I don't got to I don't got to worry
about like am I late for a meeting like
I I just all I have to do is just be
like get food get water good I actually
thought about that before cuz you ever
had those weeks where it's like too much
paperwork too much taxes too much
[__] let's go to the woods can I
just like go to prison so I'm free from
all
this that's cuz you're Swedish that's
how fair Swedish prisons are just
different yeah yeah you got the Swedish
prison Outlook that's not
fair I'm going just steal this bread
real quick to get a
vacation the Japanese person that make
you work like 8 hours a day yeah the
manly Earth should drop everything
you're doing and just build a cabin in
the woods C in the woods would be hype
that would be hyp would be sick yeah I
would love that I don't know I feel like
it depends on how bad the apocalypse is
if it's not fun then I'm like why what's
the point of
surviving huh you're checking the vibe
first yeah checking the vibe first you
know if if I'm like if I'm like in a
zombie apocalypse and I'm like oh I'm
[__] kidding my zombie parents or
zombie friends I'm like do you re
there's like a convention for bunkers in
a bunker definitely is and then there
just a bunch of like bunker people who
surviv and they're like yeah say
apocalypse con they're in a bunker yeah
it might be they're probably in the
water there that'd be lame I wouldn't
want to be bunker
boy where would you be in the top of a
tree or something yeah top of a tree top
of a tree tree he said the tree I just
said yes he didn't have to this is why
you won't survive you're listening like
a sheep you're not thinking for
yourself what would be the prime
location Australia no Japan we
established come on the cherry blossom
and the
sa I would sit patiently what does the
cherry blossom add to your survival it's
standing just just makes you feel I
would sit patiently at the bottom of a
sakro tree with my Kat in my hand
waiting for my next victim enemy an
enemy comes up behind you oh I
see dead before I draw My
Sword I feel like life would be greatly
improved if we did have that a [__]
they have an anime they're like ah I
sensed your Aura what you know in anime
when they're like I can oh yes yeah I
feel like life would just be so much
cooler if we all had
Aura I feel like we do have AA though we
don't [__] have Aura people have Aura
we have Vibes like Ora like you walk in
a building the difference what's the
difference like I can tell your strength
level you walk into a building I'm like
ah a worthy opponent has stepped into
this building bro I I sat next to Lady
beard for 2 hours I people definitely
have that's not or that's volume that
was just that was
loud it's an auditory
AA like a tangible aura that we can feel
and look at and measure what you want
out of all things well have you never
felt that when like say like someone
who's like really really famous is in
the same room as you no it's cuz they or
as weaker than
[Music]
mine so you do believe in the or no but
but if I no but if I did though it mine
would be bigger or if someone like you
really respect or like really really
like for instance is like that's your
brain doing funny little tricks on
yourself is that not what the [__]
all I'm I'm talking about a tangible
real thing oh like something you can see
no no I guess maybe we could see it I
don't know but like you can like
actually like someone walks behind you
like anime you're like ah yeah I sense
him his his power has is become my
vicinity be you want anime to be real
yeah I guess what I'm asking is it too
hard to ask like I just want
nen I feel like other
people already in my space too much all
right I don't want to or you you guys
been footsy in the whole [__] episode
what are you talking about well that's
love
[Laughter]
that's that's a different time of
world oh Christ had you been watching
the squid game the new squid game that's
come out as well you will that be
relevant by the time the episode comes
out I don't think it's relevant the
moment it's not even relevant now like
every wrote it off cuz it was like the
first ever was so [__] and wish it was
it was really bad yeah well I I think
it's just because the conversation has
changed you know like back back I saw
good opinion on it it was like you know
Back in the Day game shows used to be
about like I'll take my family on
vacation I'll buy them the car they want
now it's like I'm in like $50,000 in
debt and I just want to pay rent and so
it's kind of like the dynamic of game
shows have shifted from being like an
extra amount of money for people to
spend what game shows with the car why
well you know like back in when you were
a kid right you watch a game show and
they be like what are you going to spend
the money on it's like we're all going
to go on vacation fortune or like
Jeopardy I'm I'm going to get a new car
the new you know and and now it's kind
of shifted from I have $50,000 talking
really yeah you think prizes all [__]
too like no there us be some pretty
[__] good prizes back in there I I
feel like I've seen compilations of
people winning [__] and they're just
like wow thank you well some game shows
but there was always like Who Wants To
Be A you know like Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire that's been going on for
decades I feel like it's not that black
and white I feel like it's gotten worse
but I mean back in the day I remember
most of the time people just wanted to
pay off their mortgage whenever they'
win game shows yeah maybe this is just
my biased like memory but that's what I
remember yeah but I I guess the people
don't even a lot of people can't even
afford to have Mor
it's I think I think it's not all of it
but it's definitely some of it and then
on top of that it's like hey it's the
opposite of what the message of squid
game was yeah but is it fun yeah you're
right it's complete opposite but is it
fun yeah I liked it yeah I should watch
it I I was meaning to watch it so I
could form an accurate opinion on it um
but if you like trash TV I guess I
[__] love trash TV yeah you are a
trash TV corner like Survivor I love I
love Survivor even though it's like a
terrible show uh it's just fun what's
yours and martia's favorite trash TV
show again no no we're not talking about
that I'm going to tell her they like
watching selling that's such a [__]
show the thing is like when you're a
parent you have no brain capacity after
9 pm I just need to watch the dumbest
[__] on Netflix like I don't care
whatever well the UK has like 15 of
those shows all with like different is
really good at making those shows they
love them one of the most popular shows
on all the [__] time was uh uh it was
like home or away and it was basically
like someone would be like I want to
live in Australia but I don't know if
it's right for me and then they would
show them two houses be like look at
this [__] amazing house in Australia
for this much M I've seen this it was in
Spain too yeah in Spain they had they
had a series for Australia they had a
series for like Spain and they had the
whole thing and it was like it was
always like better abroad they like I
just like the UK and it it's quite nice
yeah they never picked a lot of the time
they didn't pick Australia cuz it was
just daunting I imagine yeah probably
it's like 14 hours away it's like
there's nothing there just especially
for a British person yeah yeah well I
like you know I have no threats
whatsoever when it comes to like animals
or like natural disasters or anything
like that and then I'm going into
Hardcore Minecraft essentially you know
true what was the what was the show uh
in UK you have the one where they show a
body
part yeah this blows Americans Minds
when you show it still blows my mind as
well cuz when I was l in the UK I just
forgot that it existed and I turned on
Channel 4 and it was just good old UK
it's I think it's actually it's such an
amazing idea cuz it like almost
desexualized the human body in a way
whil while still definitely using sex
like sexualizing the body to their
advantage because everyone is so normal
and not presented in the way that is
sexy that it's like I I don't find any
of this attract there's like an initial
hook of like oh you get to see a bunch
of naked people on TV and you're like oh
that's clearly just trying to you know
use sex to sell and then you when you
start watching you're just like yes you
know that that critique on her that
woman is pretty valid like his left not
is a little bigger it's yeah it's it's
really bizarre cuz you go from watching
like if you have watch like you know you
you see porn and then you watch this
you're like it's it's they're showing
the same bodies but it's entirely
entirely different and you walk away
feeling very different things from each
one but that's how they get past the
show of showing naked people it's
educational education but I think it
just stopped airing it just got it just
got canceled yeah rest in peace I didn't
like the show I just thing is hilarious
I mean it was certainly amazing to show
American people and they were like what
the [__] this is on TV it was aw yeah
you can has the best trash I'm trying to
think what some really good trashy TV
shows I mean come down with me is also a
classic from that's not trash TV that's
just that's crash that's that's golden
standard that's gold boring no you're
wrong so we got Gregs and now you don't
like come down with me Bally you didn't
[__] live in the UK I feel like
people like to watch it because they
think like oh I would make it so well
you you like watching it cuz you like
seeing people care so much about
something so dumb oh really yeah I think
like you watch people who like they get
really into it they're like I'm going to
[__] vote Sarah down two points oh we
did actually get into it now I remember
okay okay okay it is actually pretty
good think about it we did watch one
season all right UK citizenship giving
back oh which is the one where they have
to get married too oh um don't tell the
bride don't tell the bride no no no is
it that one uh it's the one where oh the
guy plans the wedding
yeah which is clearly so fake but it's
so hilarious he be like I think um my
wedding should be a [__] Ewok theme
so I've spent I've spent all the I've
basically they would have to spend
£10,000 on a wedding without the bride
knowing anything my favorite episode of
that was like the the dude was like I
have a brilliant idea I'm going to do it
on a pig farm oh yes I remember this one
I watch all of and the girl was just
mortified she was like I'm what do you
expect and the dude standing there like
I thought it was a good
idea [__] idiot I saw one where a
dude uh decided to it's definitely fake
oh yeah yeah a dude decided to put his
wedding in a cave he he sick he didn't
know that the mother of the bride had a
fear of caves so she
couldn't so the mother of the bride
their daughter outside the The Producers
were [__] riding heat with that one I
KN they knew what they were doing what
was the shittiest wedding B I know I
mean Pig one is the P the P there also a
few that just like were disasterous like
nothing went right like I'm in [__]
Primark buying the groomsman suits is
there any was there any wedding in that
show where it went right yeah there's a
few yeah there's quite a few are happy
yeah they I mean you know some some of
them it turned out they really loved
each other and even though a lot of
things went wrong on the day it just
like everything just that was always the
message of the show feel good it's it's
still feel good I I wonder I I wonder if
some of them got like actual marriages
afterwards or if that was their real
marriage I wonder don't know I yeah I
don't know get a free wedding yeah I
guess you do get a free wedding
yeah
you put it like that damn I'll I'll play
your wedding okay don't worry about it
this wedding is sponsored
by also just me or that just been a huge
uptake of just reality cooking shows as
well cuz every time on my Netflix
they're so bad always it's so easy to to
film and produce a cooking show that's
not you don't have to get anything crazy
you just get a bunch of chefs and and
get a bunch of kitchens and you're done
I'm just like kitchen nightmare like it
peaked with Kitchen Nightmares and
nothing has even come close to touching
like has come close to touching that
Iron Chef Iron Chef is watch a few
episodes recently really fun it's just
great show what a great show I haven't
seen it what is it it's the old Japanese
kind of um you know it's like cooking
Battle Royale they would have two teams
battle each other with like and there
would be an ingredient of the day M and
it would usually be like the Challenger
Chef would like step in and then Iron
Chef would have like there'd be like
three different chefs with three
different Cuisines and
the Challenger ship would have to go up
against professional pick one oh they
they' give him one it doesn't sound good
at all no no but then but then imagine
it's all in Japanese right so then
they're dubbing over the Japanese the
dub the Dub's pretty good the dub is the
best and they they they mimic all of the
Japanese like mannerisms in the do it's
so good you like Hasan Hasan what does
this mean he's like well actually I'm
glad you asked Koto s this is how we do
that um and then uh like uh there's
there's like they build story lines so
there was like this one I watched one
recently there's a storyline where he
beat The Apprentice and then the whole
Squad came like 50 of this like like
Clan from this family he was like no
this won't do beat my better Apprentice
beats the better Apprentice like no no
no beat the vice president of the clan
beats him he's like all right well I'll
do it next episode you'll face the boss
and it's just like what is this Pokemon
ass writing but it's so funks it's so
goofy check it
out literally shokugeki yeah it's
literally
Shoki yeah yeah
it's where are some good Japanese
reality TV oh well there's a fair few
that are pretty good there's one at New
Year's that I recommend watching oh
can't laugh one they'll can't laugh one
and also they do this I think they were
the first to do it they're like
literally they get like a bunch of
panels and I guess GED is always on it
it's the pro oh kak GI yeah where they
do this thing where every year they'll
have they'll give them like two things
or three things and they'll be like
which one is the expensive and cheap one
okay that's so they'll give you two
wines you taste them and everyone has to
pick and then of course GED I think it's
rigged a little bit I it might be a
little bit G always gets everything
right oh really he's
G and it's to say like you are the
you're like the immaculate Taste of a
human being you're the perfect most
refined taste they'll they'll do a bit
where they'll be like they'll play the
same piece on like a $10,000 violin and
a $10 violin they'll be like which one's
the expensive one yeah how would you
okay yeah would the celebrities are just
guessing but what's really funny is that
like at the start of the show everyone
starts off as like they have this like
subtitle which is like you're an aade
celebrity because you're just like so
refined and every time you get a
question wrong you get downgraded and
the way they treat them on the show gets
dowed so starts off like everyone's like
has like you know really nice like
chairs to sit on and like really nice
food and then the more you get wrong
they just like at the end of it you just
disappear from the frame it's really
they literally just edit it's only on
new year new good it's really good even
if you don't understand anything it's
visual as well that it's it's really fun
it's definitely one I recommend and
there's also the one that I kind of like
and I wish that other countries did this
was the
youim what is it you yeah yeah why why
did yeah it's B basically the show where
uh the the the whole idea of the show is
they wait at like major airports like
hanadel Narita and then they go up to
foreigners coming to Japan and they go
oh why are you in Japan okay and then
they go oh I'm doing blah blah blah
they're like
bag foreign to not it's not it's
actually to credit not set up at all
it's literally just like where do you
want us to meet you what you do I know
because I've been stopped twice for I st
people filming right where people went
out so I was like yeah that's probably
that that's what it is yeah oh wow and
so they they'll just follow a random
foreign person and some some just them
going to their hotel well no no they'll
be like they'll be like what are you
what what are you come to these trips so
if he's like I'm going to go fishing on
a boat in the middle of the ocean
they're like okay tell us when we'll
meet you there and they film that so
they film foreigners that come to Japan
only foreigners but I feel like don't
they just I'm going to go to Shibuya
Square well they don't they don't yeah
they don't take people they be asking if
someone's like someone's like I'm going
I'm coming here to compete in the
baseball championships like oh can we
follow you oh wow and I guess cuz it's
so this is this is the like Japan
doesn't like people filming right but if
you have massive clout with TV shows I
swear you get led into everywhere I
swear that they they just walk into
everywhere with this camera crew right
dude the moment you say like oh we're
with NHK TBS any
[Applause]
go
ahe so they're just following them
there's some really cool stuff to get up
to I'll check that out that sounds good
yeah those really interesting my
favorite one of those was like the the
guy who had never tried surfing before
came to Japan to go surfing in Okinawa
oh wow and it's just like you follow
this dude and he just goes all the way
to OKO and he's like yeah I've never
surfed before but I'm going to try it
here and the entire time is just
watching this guy struggling yeah that
sounds bad I he it's not that good it's
really like I saw one where it was like
this guy wanted to learn he planned to
learn to make Tatamy with like a Tatamy
making why would you want to do that I
guess cuz
really I thought I thought it was kind
of neat that it and that there was a guy
and it was literally like a 90-year-old
guy he like [__] fine I'll I'll help
you do it he's like all right wait how
he how did you learn that kind know but
he was with he was like in this guy's
house for like three months just
learning to make taty
mats found the one wee like just going
10 levels deep into Japanese I don't
know how they find these D I guess they
literally just harass everyone like what
are you doing what you they literally
just go up to everyone who looks foreign
and they just ask um it's it's always
very it's a really fun show um Japan has
a lot of shows that kind of Pat Japan on
the back they're like they have a lot of
food shows about like everything a lot
of the TV shows they put on on on
television Japan are like about how good
Japan is and all the cool things in
Japan we do not have anything like this
in the UK it just does not exist no I
think you do we have some that are like
yeah like historical things you
literally just referenced it earlier
with the show moving to Australia and
like no I'll live no that's not like
that's that's no that does not make the
UK look good at all like you could have
such a good life in Australia look how
much more she gets paid she like I
decided not to move from scunthorp I
like it and know but that makes it seem
like it's just so quaint and lovely here
no the only the only thing that I think
makes the UK look kind of good that like
I don't know they just show off some
nice home sometimes or they Antique Road
Show like no oh I remember my mom used
to watch Antique Road anti Road show is
a classic Antique Road Show is my
comfort show wait did they have an
Australian version or is it the British
one uh it's the we had both originally
they so anti antiques are there in
Australia that's a great question the
oldest it gets is 250
years they bring in something like I
think it's pretty nice like this is a
5,000 year old Relic from King Edward I
four how did you find this in your
basement meanwhile the Australian one is
like oh that looks pretty nice is like
yeah my dad made it last week it's I I
saw I saw an article in the UK uh
recently on BBC news they were like oh
yeah family finds that Garden a a garden
ornament was indeed World War I
shell what it was an active bomb shell
that's and then the story was some dad
some guy's dad found it on the beach
thought it looked nice painted it red
and just stuck it in the garden and then
this is my favorite bit they're like hey
I don't know how someone found this out
they're like we found a bomb in your
back Garden we need to remove we need
Evac neighborhood like
no he's like I'd rather I'd rather die
than you get rid of this bomb and so
then eventually they convinced them
whether they're like okay we think it's
okay to take it out and blow it up
somewhere else Jesus
Christ uh Garden yeah Garden or in UK UK
explosions oh look at this this is what
they were willing to this little red
thing I saw I saw the picture of it and
I was like this is [__] this is not
worth it doesn't even look good what
this was a and how the [__] did they
have this the most bombass looking thing
that looks like a bomb straight up found
that just lying on the streets
apparently apparently when they had like
something dirty or something they would
whack it to get like the dirt
[Music]
out Jesus Christ and I was like this is
the most UK thing
ever it looks really nice just casually
have a fcking does never below you never
hear about like you always hear people
if it hasn't blown up in like 100 it's
not going to blow
well odds are it's not going to blow I'd
win that kind of crazy i' know I'd
win well I wouldn't die but I
don't else
neighbor someone else might neighbor
doesn't have it in him he doesn't have
the ego to
survive why is it sweet when I drink
from this I don't get it you call
everything sweet Felix it's water I feel
like you had something else in this and
water [__] up
TS is it okay
sure I mean we could just Gaslight you
that's been the whole
episode
is is there a certain age you're looking
forward to for the for the child yeah
sorry I sorry both why not both for both
for both uh no it's all downhill for me
from here you are you have
I I went to [__] Sweden bro everyone
who was like 60 looked they were 40 and
they looked amazing oh yeah you guys
went to Sweden read and review let's he
let's he I saw that Norway food wasn't
as good I said Norway food wasn't as
good both me say yes it wasn't as good
it wasn't as good okay yeah what else
was good about Sweden uh there was a lot
that was so much green yeah yes we don't
have any this is trees that's more than
normal I I've never breathed an air that
felt that clean before really yeah going
to Stockholm I was like I took a breath
uh and isn't even that clean that's
that's exactly what every SW I talk
to it's cleaner than the rest of the
wall what the [__] it only goes up from
there they like they're on the stank
side of stank side well I asked you I
was like you know why should I go eat
cuz you funny enough you just texted me
as I was flying into Sweden okay and I
was like what do I do yeah and you were
like eat this uh pastry uh you
recommended this oh K yeah and I tried I
I I didn't have it what the [__] dude I
told you I told you as well did you yes
I had said Can bullet and me I was going
right [__] up I saw it in the airport
and I thought I don't want to get an
airport one so I feel like I didn't want
to get it not like it yeah and then I
instead what end up happening is we had
lunch and we had a show so I didn't end
up eating it but we did go to that
restaurant recommend and they were that
restaurant was Godlike I'm going to
remember those meatballs for the rest of
my life I am I'm genu the meat I am
genuinely genuinely willing to go back
to to Stockholm just for that meal it
was that good yeah remember I told you
about the place I was like I don't know
cuz my sister recommended it for me
first she she sent a bunch of like cool
hipster plays I'm like I think they just
want like good food and she's like okay
this one but there's only old people
that go there that's how you know it's
good that's how you know it's good so I
was like okay yeah I I I I told people
online I was like yeah man I went to
this restaurant and uh and they were
like what is it I'm like I don't know if
I want say I don't know if it's like a
personal thing someone in the comments
figured out what it was based off a very
vague description no idea guess not
stockum is not that big I I figured it
out and I was like okay well I mean fair
enough everyone should have get to enjoy
it it was expensive but it was really
really good right those [__] Swedish
meatballs I mean I can never recreate
them no no and neither should you that
was impressive too much power I guess
it's like you go anywhere where you get
the local dish it it's going to be
better when you
had now now I realize is like you
probably only had Ikea meatballs yes so
obviously like actual meatballs will
tast everything's going to be but I've
always thought of Meatballs as like kind
of a whatever dish it's just meatballs
right how much can you make it the on
are not actually good we just play along
cuz it's it's [__] it's actually well
the that's like our church can't say
anything bad about
it the last time I went to ik I was like
this tastes like ass they're like
rubbery they're so rubbery I've always
why does everyone gas this up so much I
thought this was it no no we just have
to go along spit SP of there got you got
you got to take the double use when you
get them there no way just getting all
of them all right what else was good
about Sweden let's here that's well we
were there for like a day well I want
hear we didn't air was good that was
good the vi the vi the vibe of s was
like really [__] hate s live really
yeah they're so
Rude Dude I I remember when going back
and some [__] in SW we call him like
a rich person [__] uh people did not
were not like they weren't the
friendliest in no they [__] they have
the scooters
everywhere my
God Jesus
Christ [__] chill out bro God damn
bro it's just a scooter it ain't that
deep I'll fix it he reacted like my
family the scooters in Japan now have
you seen them holy [__] it's it's this
is come full circle someone died from
the scooter they got hit by a I mean I
mean it's not very safe we'll fix his
later okay fix I think you were the one
that fixed it originally last time you
came oned it yeah he post now he's going
to have to Repose it again godamn Paul
gone a
figure wait do you uh do you do you he
do you do you hate E Scooters I mean
okay listen I I hate them but I do admit
I kind of like doing it sometimes but I
I think they shouldn't be in the city
why not wait let's not change topic I
want to hear about Sweden okay all right
all right I I like the vibe of Stockholm
because it's like it has like a quaint
feel to it at least the part that we
were at okay so's cool yeah yeah so I
liked it again it's hard to discern L I
didn't spend enough time there
but I'm going back for the meatballs
okay uh Norway was was I I like L if it
makes you feel better that's all I want
to
hear Norway Let's Hear It come on um the
food we had was okay it was it was okay
only eat food and breathe air what else
did you do yeah that's all we had time
you just described
living my life although the coffee shop
was way better in Norway than it was
in they had like beats it was pretty
good there actually I like the be eats
the most well next time we go to Sweden
what do you recommend is uh what we got
to do what do we got to do oh you got to
go into summer beautiful summer we have
this there's this um propaganda slander
movie called Midsummer oh horor film I
showed it to you why is itanda and
slander well opposite I didn't know the
word sorry I'm English slanderous
slanderous thank you yeah we have this
beautiful tradition Midsummer and they
turn it into a horror movie oh really
wait what is the normal Festival just
fun what do you normally do you just get
shitfaced and go out in the fields with
your friends ex the fields well that's
what Midsummer was wait what do you what
do you just get [__] fced you just get
[__] fced yeah oh okay this beautiful
tradition what have they done to it uh
we dance around the fertility pole and
saying little FRS yeah wow I I want to
experience that yeah that's really do
you actually dance around a pole yes
yeah fertility pole so yeah it's it's a
how how accurate is the movie then about
nothing
cuz I I do remember the place and sweet
and I watch it I'm like those are not
Sweedish bushes why why was it you find
out he's Stony or some [__] what are you
rainbolt
ston oh my God yeah that sounds fun I
want to do that no wait but hold on in
Midsummer don't you eat the [__] sing
yeah yeah people usually do people
actually like period and it's good movie
in the movie in the movie in the movie
in the movie not real not real is it is
it the one with the period blood in s
soing in the movie they had like they
opened the can the per we don't eat our
period
blood this is what I'm saying hold on
people believe itm hungry H hungry in
Japan they give you the when you have
your first period people give oh s yeah
yeah kind ofd R
weird red rice what when in Japan there
is a tradition where when girls come of
age and they have their first period say
no more I don't want to know I don't the
family gives them
rice can I how do I leave the
podcast I can't skip
forward um yeah
so do you like it uh I I never actually
it it looks vile it smells like you you
will want of vom it but I just want to
try just to say yeah I'm sure it's good
I'm sure it's good but I've heard from
pry sure you like I'm I've heard from
every like person who was eating it on
the internet who is Swedish because I
watched I think it was like some [__]
Buzzfeed video where they get a bunch of
Swedish people that eat cing and they're
all just like yeah this doesn't taste
the same when you're not shitfaced oh
really you need to be [__] so I go to I
go to Sweden right what do I get what's
the food what's the meal what do I got
to get other than the obvious ones other
than no no other than just meatballs is
there anything else oh yeah there's a
lot of lot of nothing there's just
nothing
tacos what
burritos or taco Friday yeah Taco Friday
what the [__] yeah why do they have that
in Norway well Taco Friday Taco Fridays
yeah what up I think it was a marketing
it was a marketing thing I think I
remember T Tuesday does it right CU
there was there was this thing that they
were really proud about in in Sweden
during our show it was where you um have
like a coffee break or a break during
the day oh they yeah F they were really
proud about this they started it doesn't
make sense cuz it's like they started
scre take a break and have a
coffee yes no we it's F yeah but then we
asked the crowd we were like what's
what's FICA and then they went
yeah f f mentioned that was what they
voted as like canal and some St that was
what they voted as a number one thing
that they do better than anyone else oh
yeah taking a break isn't that good is
it chill is it nice it's hyp do you sto
F now no okay and I don't get it to be
honest wait really why not coffee break
like yeah I I [__] with it yeah I love
coffee I love you do coffee breaks right
yeah
yeah I might
F yeah is it cool no guys I'm I'm not
I'm not a I'm not getting a coffee break
I'm doing a f I'm feing right now [__]
up soing with the Bros yeah also there
was a we noticed the big rivalry it
seemed like Sweden was just had a
rivalry with everyone and everyone had a
rivalry made in
Sweden especially Sweden and
Denmar yeah there was a lot
of yeah that I know yes a lot to hate
about yeah I I get it I get it actually
and the swedes are just like firing in
all directions like putting out every
fire but I mean it was it was a lot of
fun it was definitely I definitely want
to go back like to properly experience
it cuz again we I'm just going back I'm
going to that restaurant every day I
realized maybe there's not that much to
do I think about it why did you move
well cuz there wasn't that much to do
uh I said in it's for everyone else to
enjoy
Sweden I removed myself w What A M I I I
should start saying that about Wales
what do I leave to really just allow it
to breathe just give us some space I had
to leave some fun for the rest of yeah
cuz I was wondering this seems like a
pretty nice place why would you want to
you I was actually thinking like cuz I
just met marsy and took off like
and I was like you better not do this
[__] to me I was like 22 I'm done I'm
out I was like damn you moved to the UK
over this I was like that is a crazy
that a
crazy like Japan makes sense but then I
was like yeah UK off to Sweden I was
like oh that's an interesting choice I
mean I guess it just made you like Japan
even more when you go to the UK and
you're like wow nothing work the food's
not good and then I come to Japan
everything works and the food's great
yeah but the winter suck in Sweden like
it's so dark you go to school I remember
going to school and like you're at the
bus station and you can't even see your
friends cuz it's so dark you're like
what the [__] you're here there's it's
just so pitch black and then you come
home and it's pitch black and it's like
oh sking fun yes we have a lot of skiing
you tell like you don't like it that
much we don't really have
mountains that's nor got to go to Norway
yeah we have we have Salon it's like a
hill get
a it's like a small Mountain damn Norway
really did get everything they got the
oil they got the mountains they got the
they got the Beautiful the Sweden at
least have the uh the the Aurora
Borealis kind of stuff or is that all
Norway too they got that too we get it
up north okay where no one
is same in Norway though on the border
of
Norway damn Norway really got at all huh
yeah now I can see why Norway was not
really really beefing with anyone no
they just yeah cuz whenever you see
anything on all like the things are like
oh yeah yeah it's Norway number one
Sweden number two everything Norway's
like I have no
enemies well yeah I'd have no enemies if
I had all the [__] money I what the
[__] why don't they have all the money
it's so unfair they got all the money my
Grandad said this on his deathbed he was
like he was just talking [__] and he
really yeah yeah was like Felix they
have no
defenses strike them now
take them take the land it's time to
claim I'm on a mission is really why I
started YouTube your grandad R Felix
they have no
defenses come
closer they they so [__] funny it's
so [__] funny they have nothing we
have all the weapons they're not
expecting it what are they going to do
yeah true I'm just saying you probably
shouldn't joke about that but yeah also
yeah that's that's the kind of [__] I
want to say on my
deathbed just mad talk just mad talking
[__] about everyone just say the most
unhinged like not politically correct
[__] oh God my God do you still think
Sweden Swedish Winters are worse than
British Winters cuz I [__] despise
British win Bri so good wait British
wins are so good no because British wins
are the
worst but you're saying you're saying
having noticed you're you're saying this
without having experience Swedish yeah
also also G you lived in the
southernmost point of the UK you did you
did not live in the UK you lived in
basically France light all right I want
to hear it you didn't live I live right
in the [__] middle no no yes yes you
also lived in the South you don't know
[__] I know how [__] it was yeah that's
because you were in the south in the
north we got snow it was [__]
nice wet it wasn't it wasn't even
because you C it was wet you two down
south to get the fu it snows once every
3 years for 5 minutes exactly the north
it was great it was cozy we had snow it
was fun all right it was [__] nice
all right [__]
you [__] YouTu go back to Sweden okay
that's the tax that we pay for living in
the better country oh sorry live better
part of the country sorry listen listen
we like we like being poor in the north
all right we love it we love it it's a
choice it's we actually don't want money
I've been to Wales and all they had was
sheep and Hills so what do you mean you
said Wales was nice why you turn it on
me now why you tur it on me now you said
[__] you
okay listen Sweden's cool Sweden's
cool you went to like the weird Yeah you
mentioned this to me you Meed like the
weird Italian Town Portugues Portuguese
oh yeah yeah that was cool uh p p that
was a really cool place I like I like
whales but I I do remember I don't
remember if I said I feel like I said
this last time but people were like this
is not my I posted all these photos it
was all sunny and everyone's like this
is not my
whals # my we do we do get like 10 days
a year where it's Su yeah I think I went
that week but I also like the gloominess
cuz
it okay hold up let me let me say
something let cook let him cook it's
like you probably really appreciate the
Swedish Summers because the winters are
so dark and gloomy I really appreciate
when but UK doesn't get a summer okay we
do we do it's kind of warm it's we we
have a good one week listen yeah and
then it's too warm no AC see and you're
just [__] you're like this sucks bring
it back
comes in yeah well at least we have
crisps those are good good crisps
there's crisps everywhere yeah but they
suck UK crisps are by far the best did
you have them in Sweden no what the [__]
did you have the Estella sour cream
onion well that's what we we have the
dip you never dip dip for crisps yes you
get the sour cream with the mix you know
that that tells me your Cris can't stand
on
their they can't stand on they can't
stand on their own flavor no [__] I'm
out of
this God damn all right well I guess we
can wrap it up there we there he's done
he's done slander next time you can okay
you you should come out firing next
Trash Talk man welcome the trash T hey
look at all these patrons though so they
support the show they're like dunking on
Sweden I'm sure but uh Hey if you like
to support the show and
then the Norwegian
patrons rise up Norwegian patrons now's
your time to shine hey if you like to
support this show then go over to our
patreon patreon.com traste also follow
us on Twitter send memes on the subr if
you hate our face listen to us on
Spotify and hey if you like to check out
this week's uh brand new patreon
exclusive content then here's a quick
5sec clip of it Rollo M on pass of Glory
pass of Glory probably I think it might
be P of Glory now born Supremacy no pass
of Glory do you even know this film no
but it looks old and if if it's on this
list it's probably a banger uh where's
my chat out uh yeah go follow
we found some Dad off the street Japan
so we got to shout out the small
aspiring artist uh want to shout out
your channel C on 111 mil Subs so please
guys
come 112 let's do it 112 come on let's
go even if you're Norwegian whatever
just like please sub just just hate sub
at least let's do it 112 come on let's
go well thanks for coming on F pleasure
until the last
minutes all right we'll see you guys
next week bye
[Music]
bye